[Music]
after Napoleon comes Hannibal the next
great General in world history will
receive a cinematic Masterpiece in 2024
for which director antoan fuka will be
responsible in the leading role is
Denzel Washington according to deadline
streaming giant Netflix is planning a
Monumental historical epic about the
legendary General the man who crossed
the Alps on elephants and almost brought
down Rome The Equalizer director Antoine
fuka will direct the project while Den
Washington will be taking on the
starring role this will be the sixth
collaboration between the two in
addition to the three equalizer films
they also brought the Magnificent 7 and
Training Day to the big screen for the
latter Washington was awarded the
Academy Award for best actor in a
leading role the actor wanted to take on
the role of Hannibal 20 years ago
however family circumstances prevented
this and so the project was put on ice
for a long time now though the biopic
which is to be written by screenwriter
John Logan is finally getting back on
track Logan has already impressed with
the scripts for Martin scores The
Aviator and Ridley Scott's Gladiator
making him a connoisseur of historical
material it remains unclear when
Hannibal will be released on Netflix but
we'll keep you up to date as
[Music]
always